your body would be working overtime to  deal with the excess heat that means  you'd be using more energy to stay at a  normal temperature you could experience  heat stroke or even heat edema which  would make your hands and feet swell you  may not survive unless you get out and  into a cold bath right away and even if  you cool down there's a chance that you  could experience organ and neurological  dysfunction within a year  during this bath your heart rate would  increase and you would start feeling  dizzy  now it's just a matter of time before  your blood vessels leak  this could cause violent hemorrhaging  and make you puke blood  if you managed to crawl out of this  cesspool  your body would be a wreck